now to the united states police say that
the man suspected of shooting dead at
least six people at a fourth of july
parade
in chicago had been planning the attack
for weeks the 22 year old initially
escaped the scene after shooting at
crowds from a rooftop
he was later arrested police say the
attack appeared to be completely random
and that the gunman was not targeting
any specific
groups
yeah so what more do we know about what
happened let's go now to our
correspondent in washington dc mr
muskanda she has been covering the story
for us good evening to you sami so what
else do we know and what did the police
tell us about this attack
brent officials have been releasing more
details about this terrible shooting as
you said we've learned that this was a
premeditated attack the shooter had
cased the building and the area where
this parade was taking place he had
women's clothing on as disguise to blend
into the crowd and to be able to evade
police as he was fleeing that rooftop
where he had positioned himself for the
shooting
we also learned brent that he was taken
into custody after a citizen actually
reported uh seeing the suspect's car so
police had put out these alerts uh
warning people to to keep their eye out
of course and uh a citizen actually
noticed the license plates and alerted
police and the suspect according to
authorities didn't resist arrest he is
in custody awaiting charges as for the
shooting itself more than 70 bullets
were fired into the crowd and the weapon
was
a legally purchased firearm an ar-15
style gun and we know brent that this is
a weapon that has been used in multiple
mass shootings in the u.s in recent
weeks a lot of details are still being
released brent but we should say we're
seeing so many harrowing tales of
witnesses on the ground really
describing absolute
pandemonium and we can't forget there
are people who were wounded who suffered
gunshot injuries and they are being
treated in the hospital as well
we heard earlier from police sumi that
the police apparently were not aware of
this 22 year old he did not have a
criminal record he was not on their
radar so
do we have any inkling then about what
would have been his motivation
well police are still calling through a
lot of information to determine that
motive if they have determined one they
haven't shared it with us or the public
just yet but what we do know is that
this suspect had a long and troubling
trail of social media post sprint so
there were tributes to mass shootings
that he had posted the suspect had
posted um he had numerous profiles on
different platforms he performed as a
rapper
he posted violent music videos and there
was a violent youtube video as well one
in which he depicted a stick figure in
tactical gear attacking people also
musical lyrics uh that were violent so
clearly the suspect had a deep digital
footprint and a lot of it very troubling
there were signs here
that he was in trouble and this
happening during a fourth of july
parade this was not the only shooting to
take place on independence day this year
in the u.s was it
yeah it was a violent july 4th weekend
brent according to the gun violence
archive there were several mass
shootings over this holiday weekend
we've seen these images of people
running in philadelphia when shots rang
out there at a fireworks celebration two
officers were injured in that shooting
investigators they're still trying to
figure out what happened but you know
we've been talking about the shooting in
highland park in chicago itself brent um
this was a weekend where we saw at least
57 people shot there were shootings in
other cities like kenosha wisconsin as
well so
this is just adding to a list of mass
shootings that we've seen in the us in
recent weeks unfortunately a
never-ending story sumi summa scanda in
washington sumi thank you
you